former UN Ambassador nikki Haley says
other Trump cabinet members tried to
recruit her in an effort to resist the
president's actions in an interview for
Sunday morning with CBS Evening News
anchor and managing editor Norah
O'Donnell Haley accused former White
House chief of staff John Kelly former
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson in her
words of undermining the president which
a Jang is here in studio 57 with more on
this story we should good morning to you
what else does nikki Haley saying oh
good morning nikki Haley told CBS News
those former Trump aids should have quit
if they didn't like the president's
actions and said their attempts to
circumvent him go against the
Constitution and this isn't the first
time we're hearing of staffers attempts
to go around president Trump to
undermine a president is really a very
dangerous thing speaking to Norah
O'Donnell on Sunday morning former UN
Ambassador nikki Haley doubled down on
things that senior White House officials
asked her to subvert president Trump
Haley writes in a book out this week
that then chief of staff John Kelly and
then Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
quote confided in me that when they
resisted the president they weren't
being insubordinate they were trying to
save the country the Secretary of State
tiller so went on to tell you the reason
he resisted the president's decisions
was because if he didn't people would
die you memorialized that conversation
it definitely happened it absolutely
happened and instead of saying that to
me they should have been saying that to
the president not asking me to join them
on their sidebar plan in an interview
with CBS News political contributor Bob
Schieffer last December Tillerson said
he had openly challenged the
commander-in-chief's decision-making and
I'd have to say to him well mr.
president I understand what you want to
do but you can't do it that way it
violates the law it violates the treaty
responding to Haley Kelly told Sunday
morning if by resistance installing she
means putting a staff process in place
to ensure the president knew all the
pros and cons of what policy decision he
might be contemplating then guilty as
charged
it seems those weren't the only attempts
to temper president Trump's impulses a
purported senior trump official wrote in
an anonymous New York Times column last
September that top staffers are working
diligently from within to frustrate
parts of his agenda and his worst
inclinations an anonymous editorial can
you believe it anonymous speaking at a
summit in Georgia last month Kelly said
he had second thoughts about leaving the
administration and added that he told
the president there would be
consequences for surrounding himself
with yes men don't hire someone that
would just you know nod and say you know
it's a great idea mr. president because
you will be impeached president Trump
claims general Kelly never said anything
like his warning about impeachment and
if he had quote I would have thrown him
out of office in relation to those Hali
comments the White House and Tillerson
have not responded to our requests for
comment is very curious to see what
they're thinking because some people are
saying it looks like they were thrown
under the bus and then the bus is
running over there but it does expose
what those very senior aides were saying
about President Trump so it's sort of a
double-edged sword Rex Tillerson notably
silent on this we're hearing from yeah
all right thanks wheeze you